Listen,
it's official now,
the PSOE has sealed 1 surprising agreement
with the Argentine nationalist party,
thus consolidating
1 absolute majority for the investiture of the President
Pedro Sanchez.
But that's not all,
this pact
joins the agreement previously reached with yuns,
creating 1 political alliance
which could have shocking consequences
for the future of the nation,
as we remember
that the government of Spain
is in the hands of pro-independence policies
both Basque and Catalan.
The fact is that
in 1 desperate attempt to cling to power,
has given in to PNV demands
committing to initiate 1 debate
on the reform of the state model
to recognize Euskadi as a nation.
Yes,
just as you've heard,
imagine the implications of this
for the unity of Spain.
But that's not all,
the PNV
has required the fulfillment of outstanding commitments
of the previous legislature,
as well as investment improvements,
infrastructures and rights for Basque citizens.
The viability of this pact comes as a bombshell
after PSOE and yuns signed
also 1 political agreement
and the most alarming thing is yet to come,
since next week
the most controversial point will be presented,
the amnesty law.
We are facing
the resurgence of separatist tensions
and 1 Spain under review.
I read you in the comments